welcome to google developers weekly for
December 9 2013 I'm Louis gray and this
is our highlight reel of what's
happening in the world of google
developers on the set and off the big
news from the world of google developers
last week was a general availability of
google compute engine our cloud compute
service offers ninety-nine point nine
five percent monthly SLA 24 x seven
service support for additional flavors
of linings reduce prices and much more
so you'll want to check this out
alongside the launch of google compute
engine paul rashidi debuted a ten minute
test drive here on GDL walking us
through the process of creating a
project setting up a cloud-based virtual
machine and installing a web server very
helpful and maybe even fun our more
grounded teammates in Google Analytics
Andrew Wales and Nick my love skee told
customers how to upgrade to universal
analytics and answer some of the many
commonly asked questions about the web's
favorite measurement tool every click
counts and don't we know it we were
pleased to welcome back wallets here's
ponging and mariela grayza the pair
walks through the wallet objects API
QuickStart sample setting you up to
connect your business to millions of
Google users showcasing your loyalty
programs offers and more and maps Nasir
mano marks followed on with his first
event in his new location soon to be
revealed this week's Focus Matt padding
in the Google Maps SDK for iOS Matt
padding allows you to change the visible
region of your map so that your controls
logo and copyright notices are all
aligned with your view from Milan Sandro
paga naughty dives into the promise of
html5 custom elements helping us create
new HTML code elements that are reusable
and readable even more challenging he
does the entire presentation in Italian
incredible wrapping up our studio events
for last week is the first in a series
from our google developer expert steam
and the YouTube developer squad frequent
GDL guest Jeremy Walker talks with gde
Jerry McDonald about the many
contributions that he and others have
made to the YouTube API community watch
for more interviews in coming weeks here
on the weekly wrapup around here we
think fast as
other than slow and we're always working
to make the web faster this week web
performance guru Ilya gregorich wrote
about HTTP 20 a developing protocol that
makes applications faster simpler and
more robust read ilias article to learn
in great detail how HTTP 20 will speed
up the web just go to ACM org and search
for making the web faster we also love
making it faster and easier for you to
develop great mobile apps to help chrome
devtools just got a couple of wonderful
new features first when your remote
debugging screencast lets you see your
mobile device screen right along your
tools and mobile emulation lets you
realistically emulate many device
characteristics on your desktop read all
about it at html5 rocks com that's html5
rocks calm and to make sure that you
never miss a thing from the world of
google developers subscribe to google
developers on youtube and check out the
gdl schedule at
developers.google.com/live I'm Louis
gray and I'll see you in the studio